has got a team that's come back from Sweden
let's see how those legs are for them and see
if the Hawks can take advantage of that Hawks win
the draw Nick Felino snaps one off on samsonov
rebound to Morgan Riley that pass from Max doy
in the direction of Ky yarro yarro was a game
time decision today he's got the puck now and
that one is soaked up by Arvid solder Bloom
Xfinity coming into Play Already neander stick
handling the puck John Taris with a couple of
wax off the crease neander brings it around to
go down there get your timing and uh certainly
played well last year at the end of the year
while he was with the Hawks Max doy looking
for a centering feed that was in I think that
was in originally the first one Robertson I
think will get the goal yeah slid in underneath
the pad again going side to side or dot to dot
defend against and here we see from up high you
you stop it here it's really the the Hawks have
everyone's in numbers right there there's five
red sweaters there I mean maybe two on the left
and this Puck ends up going there you see Wyatt
Kaiser's poking thinking it's going to yarn cro
in front but it ends up going to the far side
right there and DOI finds his man he'll get a
Helper on the first that is good Nick Felino
looking light on his [Applause] feet Jason
Dickinson Dickinson scores Jason Dickinson's
hot November continues and the Hawks tie it up
on Dickinson's fourth of the Season they're taking
the puck off the left boards and the Leafs Marner
had control of the puck in that very important
area of the ice just inside your own Blue Line
doesn't take care of it Dickinson brings it back
and changes the angle gets it through mccab who
doesn't close the gap on him and great shot
there going back to the Y cro Brody from Riley
Brody save solder Bloom rebound Robertson
had a whack and solder Bloom made another
save
bro bang down low and Max doy TJ
Brody cross ice feed and Kelly yarro
scores firmly on the ice on that play back door
play back to the puck carrier and that's exactly
what he does right there and and Brody finds
his man and for one of the few times on the
defensive side of you see blassic right there
he's uh going up against a right hand shot and
not a lefty so the stick is in the opposite area
and if if yarn croes a leftand shot that he's got
to The Bard line stuck in the defensive Zone
C turns and fires off the Stick of Kev mccab
score Ryan [Applause] Reeds it's 3 to one Toronto
boy Phillips and Kaiser you know you get caught
on that ice with Kev it's a long time right there
and Ryan Reeves who has been much scrutinized he's
had a good game in this one right here this is a
good pass by McCabe right to the back and you see
Kaiser is trying to drag a leg right there and it
goes right through the hole been really laboring
Taylor radish snaps one off sov Morgan Riley ahead
of him Murphy plays the bounce Murphy looking for
a shot for Tyler Johnson standing with you through
it all well this is that good effort right here I
I mean Johnson goes in first to get some help from
radish this is just hard work moving your skates
getting in on the four check it's a two on three
then a terrific play by Murphy to keep that puck
alive and it ends up going right on the tape to
Johnson Nifty pass from Seth and here's William
nander look out nander save solder Bloom oh
look how quickly that happens in transition
right there Hawks get a great chance but there's
neander in all alone and that's a power move by
neanders a right hand shoty protects the puck
with his left and then cuts across I don't think
solder blo know knew that he had that puck but
a good save Nicholas Robertson for Morgan Riley
the save by solder Bloom and with Puck dangling
on the crease six shots on goal in the game in
Columbus for Johnson that whole line actually had
a plethora of opportunities in that game against
Columbus Bor Boris kachuk as well and that's Jason
Dickinson the Hawks score again it looks like it's
Dickinson second of the game ends are on their
feet off a a soft dumping right there that gets
your first man in and there he he is and Anderson
does a good job on a one-on two and here samsonov
has no idea this is in the net but give Anderson
a ton of credit in this hockey game for getting
into the trenches and winning battles like that
right there although it went off the heel of the
Stick of lagon right there to Dickinson goalie
on the goal line and thanks for coming it's a
3-2 hockey game against the Matthews line
for the maple leavs Blackhawks trying to
sweep the two- Game season series with Toronto
this season they won 4-1 in Toronto Dickinson
scores throw those hats on the ice it's a holiday
weekend hat trick for Jason Dickinson the first of
his career again on the hunt and and it looked
at that point like the play was dead but a bad
pass by the Maple Leafs good job aggressively by
Felino there not not there but mcen now thinks
he's got an outlet pass in the middle that's where
Felino gets under the Stick of the forward Austin
Matthews who's sliding and out of position and by
the time he tries to make this save with his left
skate the goal tender also slides and there's room
on the stick side and that wrist shot has been
lethal Dickinson had a good camp Kev curls double
team comes intercepted by Mitch Marner Marner
shorthanded Marner a big save by Arvin soer Bloom
and he drops the [Applause] P Mitch Marner Austin
Matthews and Morgan Riley the trio for Toronto on
the ice Matthews around Dickinson Matthews stopped
by solder Bloom and there's the the the big save
with the right pad by solder Mitch Marner around
Felino behind the net Marner still on the puck
Matthews saves solder bloom rle for Seth Jones
swing and a miss he takes a spill and William
neander to extend his point streak and win the
game for Toronto that's off the pipe and neander
comes in here and he goes forehand backand and I
thought it went in it goes post crossbar post
crossbar and out and you look at the reaction
of the player with the puck on his stick and I
Neil Ander Max doy the former Blackhawk TJ Brody
inside a two to go in OT doy blocked Seth
Jones and a stop by solder Bloom Kev Bard
Bard Bard high slot oh drops down on top of the
net it's it's in it's over Hawks win in [Applause]
overtime in there and the young defenseman the
seventh overall pick takes advantage of that
there he jams it in with one hand on his stick
got enough of it Bard brings a tired group of
Leafs with him the shot goes off the knob
of the stick goes up over the glass coming
back there and there's with one hand on to
s yes and just enough to get it beyond the
goal line and pass the goal tender on the right
side Samson up terrific second effort there by
Kinski second NHL goal for Kevin Kinski
and the Blackhawks win in overtime they
sweep the season series against
the Toronto Maple Leaves and what
an exciting game I mean just a thriller
a capacity crowd it hasn't been great